vista la stragrande varietà di giochi
del tipo slither io world max io ieri è
morto mio zio il gioco che sta
spopolando di più in assoluto per adesso
che mi interessava provare la lotta ma
non l'ho provato così almeno potrà farci
più video fare più virus il gioco in
questione è all punto io
proviamo credo che la partenza è
veramente ottima perché se continua a
premere sul tasto play
neanche si parte quindi deve essere un
gioco difficile alla player chiamiamoci
abbiategrasso via dai proviamo no no io
non so anche cosa è che gioco è tra
l'altro non so che devo fare calmi non
so cosa tu fai
c'è gente aiuto non ho mai capito cosa
devo fare parte che c'è il mio nome gb
scavalca questi sono chiesto a me va beh
orca la [ __ ] lytham questo è un po
grosso un po come come il mio caso devo
smetterla di mettere gli hobby nei mini
la scusa di rimanere nel tempo anche
presidi succhiarsi cosa sta succedendo
cosa vedo vabbè banche 5 secondi sono
ultimo ma non cade nulla nel mio book
over time out tua sorella comunque però
dove ai ragazzi riproviamoci facciamo la
roma un po più seria perché faccio
veramente schifo sta roba
non pensavo partiamo subito magnate
romagna do non so se meno sorpreso io
ero quasi ero così primo portal
camminamento ne trova subito le partite
perfetto perfetto perfetto effetto sono
prima cosa devo fare devo diventare
primo ok posso rischiare gli altri non
ho capito se posso rischiare gli altri
ma va bene se ho la corona sono primo
automaticamente si possono imposto
risucchiare gli altri prevedono già
ucciso uno questo gigante come lega è
fighissimo l'unico problema è che non ho
capito non so le tattiche per fare aiuto
quando nei giochi non sono non sono
skillato non ci gioco spesso non sono
conosco le tattiche l'ultima volta ho
vinto a paper io a caso ma non si sa
come adesso non sono proprio le tate e
quindi faccio un po a caso
immagino alla potrà diventare grosso
tanto quanto un grattacielo in modo tale
da risucchiarli però non so quanto ci
metto 12 perfetto il parcheggio buono
buono
ciao sono terzo cribbio come con 64 pure
una partita pochissimo non volevo di
bollo risucchiare i palazzi maledizione
familiari palazzi ragazzi sono quarto
faccio veramente schifo però vabbè non
importa
mutu ma sono io questo non sono io ci
sono io sono io non sono io li sto
spostando hanno visto mangiando che sto
varia dall ara mangiati magia veloce che
64 che fai schifo
ecco questo buco era lo stesso nei miei
voti scolastici perfetto come facessero
ancora quart si vabbè ma il primo a 700
punti ma quanto gioca quello che si che
poco matematicamente single sono quarto
va bene a metà della classifica non è
neanche malissimo piano rega piano
perché siamo ok ma entra ma che diamine
non valeva non posso fare così schifo
all'inizio se dite è veramente difficile
se non ed e sembra una cagata ma non lo
è
c'era forse si ammazza gli altri sono
più forti ok devo provare un ammazzare
gli altri ma non l'ho fatto molto spesso
ok inglobiamo gente va beh un fidget
spin cosa storia tenendo gesù c'è un
fidget spinner un po grosso eh vabbè
lasciamo aperta solo lì ma sta gente
come ha fatto a fare tutti sti punti in
così poco tempo perché poi quale partite
durano veramente niente di più due
minuti come hanno fatto a farsi punti ma
basta lo scrivano per niente che culo
devo stare attenta la farina gialla è
però siamo rimasti in 3 quello che al
triplo dei miei punti come fa sta gente
non è una vita non vive vai vai vai vai
0 e zio dentro tutto dentro tutto dentro
le il secondo secondo secondo se diventa
ancora più grosso possibile fare con i
più grossi palazzi però non sono così
grosso
porca vacca sì per ora che in due minuti
il ma c'entra perché non scende secondo
non è male ci pensavo molto peggio il
primo ha fatto il doppio dei miei punti
questi non hanno una vita
vabbè ragazzo arriva primo ci provo e
vorrei è veramente difficile
abbiategrasso maledizione deve trionfare
abbiategrasso vieni qua a top pure tu
sia
datemi una mano tutti alzate le mani al
cielo tipo goku ma perché non entrano i
pali o bene ciao gente
devo diventare grosso scusatemi sono
abbiategrasso ma non sono abbastanza
grosso ok perfetto
il primo sta 61 punti dove gli sta
trovando quei punti lo sa solo lui
vabbè come fa come fanno essere così
grossi come come p 50 giocano con tre
giorni all anno navi non fanno i compiti
queste persone non li fanno non lavora
non fanno che fanno niente nella vita
e allora porco ski 400 punti 83
come fa a essere 400 lavori da bill
gates come se tua madre deve morire
dimmelo prima cosa a se mourinho non è
che mori sempre mori sono per un po di
tempo poi vi lasci fantastico tanto
porca vacca ho fatto cagare nord la
gente non giura non ha una vita devi
crescere subito perché se cresci ci
metti un ora e mezza perdi
ok subito albero ok ok buono buono va da
sé però davvero deve cadere deve cadere
l'albero cadi cadi non cade una sega
tombino a palo gente ok se va beh come
come fa essere a 55 giorni posto io
abbia da parte di prossima partita segue
gente segua gente vede vedo quello che
fa la gente non me ne frega niente di
vincere voglio vedere cosa fa voglio
vedere come fanno essere in tre secondi
a 100 cristo di punti come come fanno
essere cento come com'è possibile si
sono venduti la famiglia hanno venduto
il cane come hanno fatto hanno inglobato
i loro parenti come hanno fatto non lo
so guarda guarda guarda guarda cisl
guarda guarda perché gioco è poi le
macchine non entra non entrano ti
ammazzo la famiglia esco ecco alfa monet
una serie a 12 i birilli birilli pd ok
perfetto no che è caduta ingloba la la
gente non si muove cade per terra sta
fermo va beh ok quanto sta il primo ok
ci posso fare dai dai dai dai est a
partita contro vanamente non sta andando
male forse non dovevo dirlo ma non fa
niente
una mucca cosa ci fa una mucca sulle
strisce cosa diavolo visto vai vai vai
vai vai globale primo trofeo che bello
la stessa emozione l'ho provata quando
ho preso un 6 in fisica una volta ma è
lì che come non detto
come ha fatto con la diventa primo cosa
ha mangiato sua sorella me magno lui che
è un nemico cosa vedo vai vai facciamo
già tv però il palazzo immagini
mangiarli
mangia mangia mangia siamo a pari merito
praticamente mangiali però cosa stai
magnate defici allora guarda cosa faccio
seguo lui fossero succederlo se siamo
simili sono primo però lui e seguo lui
ma guardo cosa fa lui e lo mangio prima
io cioè in teoria dovrei vincere io ti
faccio così non sono primo rega ecco
come si vince devi togliere alla roba
dalla bocca degli altri quello deva
questo magno no si perfetto di secondi
ragazzo primo soffrivo nice
mi chiamo si mangia godzilla e vince so
good c'era anche marshmallow in sta
partita ci ha messo una vita e mezza a
river primo ma ce l'ho fatta ho trovato
la tattica devi seguire il primo è fatta
ridarò è semplicissimo in realtà
direi a questo punto ragazzo di passare
al nostro cavallo di battaglia che
conosciamo molto bene
l'ex group e il periodo signora tra
l'altro c'è aspetto c'è anche roba
diversa a small map big fun va bene però
va alla mappa piccola di paper io non
avevo ancora provata era bellissimo che
ero riuscito a vincere la prima partita
a caso è il primo ad amica sono un fesso
gioco sono pro vialetto fra gli altri
faccio pagare in questo sono bravo sono
io non avevano vita sociale non so
perché avremo che l'ho detto mi in
groppa non si scappa una roba fatta
decente bravo bravo pirla
complimenti volevi tua sorella morta
valga elevati sull'altro note sfiga
porca vacca che rischio no che culo
vai vai avere perfetto no non è ok
perfetto vai vai vai più grandissimo
sono fenomeni sono primo beni che nei
giochi serie di vento primo negli altri
faccio pagare com'è possibile starò la
società mi prendono un botto di spazio
non so se riesco se riescono fatto un
colpaccio buono non ho capito se tocchi
bordi se muoiono nel dubbio non lo
voglio scoprire cos'ha fatto da hai
provato e ti sei accorta di avere la zia
un po strana
veloce veloce questo qua è
difficilissimo da battere perché si
tiene attaccatissimo però ci provo cioè
nel senso non sono uno che molla subito
quindi possiamo provarci questo non sta
facendo
complimenti è rimasto solo lui paola una
partita uno contro uno zio ben e non lo
so e se riesco però qualcosa ma che
rischio più mangiato mezza mezza mezzo
terreno però vabbè questo bellissimo è
veramente difficile da battere ma dovrei
riuscirci ciao bella ma perché miss
paoli gente va dai ma l'ha fatto
vado non ci credo non ci credo mai nel c
treno ivy nota che idiota
porca mark che deficente porco schifo ho
sbagliato io regalo sbagliato che non
pensavo strasse gente mi sono convinto
ad haga non vale
evan perché quando entrano gli altri mi
ammazzano con dentro io non rischia di
ammazzare gli altri è perché se quello
lì ero io a quest'ora ero morto sei
volte ciao
se ci sono abbastanza bravo a prendermi
spazio perché la gente non se ne accorge
e poi no che ed efficiente porca vacca
per eni che vi sia questo non è il gioco
perfetto che questa veramente figo altro
che all
e tutti gli altri alle altre cagate di
prima questo gioco figo se io fossi
studio milano ragazzi
direi che per oggi va bene così sono
saturo a me piace comunque giocare
perché io sono una persona che si
tranquillizza easy quando giochi
videogiochi proprio svuota la mente poi
esce dalle sessioni videoludiche più
tranquillo di prima non avevo contento
ragazzi mi piace un sacco essere
tranquillo ragazzi io spero che vi sia
piaciuto quanto mi piace anche noi sta
cercando da tiziana sono sacrificate non
ci vediamo bene
[Musica]